Hey, what's up guys it's Grant here I know, some of you have been wondering where I've gone
Well I've got an update video coming out in the next week or two that'll explain all the answers to your questions.
I've got a big announcement to make so keep your eyes out for that video in the next week or two and i'll see you there.
Hey guys, I'm Nate, welcome back to the workshop, not too long ago, we showed you how to build your very own bullwhip
Using parracord bb's, athletic tape, and some PVC piping
Well today we're gonna go over a couple of quick lessons on how to get your bullwhip to crack well, without hurting yourself.
First is the cattleman's crack. To do the cattleman's crack you need to start out with the whip lying out straight behind you
What i'm going to do is bring
My arm up into the 12 o'clock position and the whole whip will flip up in the air around
And behind me. Once the whip is pointing behind me, not when it's above me, but when it's behind me, I'll then bring
My arm back down to the 6 o'clock position the whole whip will curl
Along, and then at the end when the fall straightens out that's where it cracks the other type of crack I was doing is called
the overhead crack
This, type of crack is actually a reversal of which direction, you're, swinging the whip
Above your head so to start out I swing counterclockwise
If you're, practicing this you, want to make sure that you can, easily swing it without it touching the ground anywhere around
you, and then when I get to about here and the whip is pointing straight behind me,
I will reverse direction in a clockwise way, and the whip, which will be swinging above my
Head will get that same curl in it that it does from the cattleman's crack and
Then this last one which again
I don't know if it has a name i just sort of figured it out it probably does have a name but i'm pretty
new at this sport
All i'm going to do is very quickly bring
My arm forward like i'm throwing a baseball sort of sidearm and then once i'm near the front i snap
My wrist to give it a little extra flick to it. Whip cracking 101!
There you have it that's three beginning, whip
cracks
There are ways that you can go in routines from one crack into another and there are probably a dozen different
Ways to crack the whip that i don't know yet
I'm just learning this myself, we also had one viewer who directed me to another video that suggested a faster way
The polish it uses some ball chain
Instead of bb's fit down inside the paracord so we're gonna try throwing one of those together and see how, well it works
*Saw cutting
Just like in the other video, my first piece of paracord is going to be long enough that it can
Stick out the back by about a foot
You'll go the length of the handle and then it will have eight feet of paracord in front of the handle
There's our eight-foot mark
Use some tape to mark, where the back of our long piece of paracord
Leaves the handle of our whip now, i need nine, more pieces of paracord, which will get progressively shorter as they go down
The length of the whip
We want our second piece of paracord to be 18 inches shorter than our longest piece and
After that every piece will shrink by, about eight inches
Images shorter cut the tape.
"10"
There, we go we've got our 10 strands of paracord so let's add some ball chain for weight
Now the ball chain is clearly, not gonna have the same amount of weight per strand, as bb's inside of paracord so we're gonna try
doubling the amount of chains, that, we have
Maybe more I don't want to go as long as our?
Longest or even our second longest cord but i am gonna measure out our third longest piece of cord to make a. Chain, that length
Now, that piece of chain, is about six feet long and this roll of chain, comes with
30 feet on it i'm going to add another piece but to make sure
We keep the taper of the whip nice and natural i'm gonna shorten this one by about four inches
I'm just gonna keep going adding
Pieces of chain, shortening it by, about 4 inches every time i have two rolls of this metal chain
and you'll probably, use all of it
That's 10 strands i think that's gonna be a pretty good weight?
We now have 10 strands of paracord and 10 strands of our ball chain let's bundle them together
Tape them up attach them to our handle and see if this whip will work
Before i tape the paracord strands together i'm gonna tape all of the ball chain strands together, hopefully they'll
Make sort of one chord and i can kind of put that in the middle of the paracord we'll see if that works at all
Start by just laying, them all flat on a piece of tape
Sticking it down and roll that up
Kind of gonna, do the same thing with the paracord strands because i think that might help
me wrap the ball chain up inside of it
Not really worrying
About what order these strands are it's not necessarily from longest to shortest it's all going to be a. Bundle in the end
might, be the trickiest part of the whole build it's getting, this little piece of paracord end
Through, the little hole that's been drilled
That wasn't so hard
All right, we have our many strands of paracord kind of surrounding the ball chain
Next step is to secure this end of everything to the handle with a, whole lot of electrical tape
As soon as i wrap this in athletic tape it'll be good to go but before i do that i like to go around
And use a little bit of electrical tape every foot and a half or so just to hold it all together
There, we have it our whip is all wrapped up it's nice and flexible which is what
We want we do still have the fall, which is exposed?
And that's the part that moves around really fast
So i think we're just about ready to test this out but there is one little addition we're gonna make
Youtube where calibur, whips
Suggested that if we added a cracker to our whip instead of just having it end in a fall it would work 50 times better
i think
We were getting a pretty good whip crack when
We just had the fall without a cracker on it but i figure if we can get any improvement on it let's try it
Before i was leaving the end of the paracord unfused so that as it
Unraveled a little bit it would act as a cracker a little bit on its own
Now, because i'm going to add dedicated cracker to it i am gonna, fuse it shut as
The calibur, whips channel, suggests in their video showing, how
to
Add a cracker instead of tying one on i'm actually going to put a small hole in the end of the fall and loop
The cracker through that so it shouldn't be able to come off at all i'm using a, nail to poke a hole right
Through, the end of my fall here
And then so it doesn't close back up when i take the, nail out i'm just gonna hit it with the lighter, again
Got a nice little eye hole, we should be able to fit a cracker
through, there pretty
easily the cracker itself i'm going to make out of one of the inside
Strands from our paracord this piece is about 18 inches long and it's definitely more than i'll need but i'll trim off any excess when
I'm finished to start let's just fold the piece of nylon string in half and we'll hold it by, that folded point
This, nylon string, is twisted together and you can see that if i twist it one direction it actually comes apart
A little bit so what i'm going to try and do is using
my, thumb, and one finger i'm going to roll the two strands apart, and
Then once they're nice and loose i'll hold, them close together, and twist them back together
You can, see that by twisting it apart first it makes it so that when they twist, back together, they hold
Themselves that way a little bit i'm now
Going to move my, grip up to where it's already twisted
And then i'm going to repeat that process for four or five inches down
This piece of thread if you've seen our video on how to make rope this is a fairly similar idea
We twist the individual strands so that they're under a little bit of tension, and then when they twist together
They, stay wound very nicely
Alright you can, now see that the two separate strands have
Become wound together for maybe five inches so now i'm just going to tie a figure eight knot
Right, where they're finished winding together as
I predicted i have a little bit of extra cord, so i'm just gonna slice that off
and now
What i want to do is sort of the opposite of when i was twisting up i want to?
Untwist these strands all the way, so they just kind of turned into individual fibers or fluff
There we go?
we have our cracker
So now let's take the end of our cracker and fit it through the eye hole in the bottom of our fall now
We want to unravel the loop in one end of the cracker so that we can, fit the other end of the cracker
through, the hole
Now, when we pull this tight?
Our cracker is tied in a knot around the end of our fall and should never be able to come off unless it breaks
There, we go we've got our ball and chain
Whip we've added a cracker onto it let's decorate the handle and then go test it out
Beautiful let's go test it out
Here we go we've got the ball chain, whip first impression, is that this definitely is lighter weight than the whip with
The, bb's in it but we're. Gonna see how. It works it does have the cracker on it maybe that'll make it easier to whip
Keep your eyes safe
whoa, there it goes
That is pretty easy?
It's a little bit quieter of a sound i think
alright let's try the other one as a comparison i
Don't know. They both crack pretty easily
With just a little bit of practice i think, we can, definitely say that the ball chain
Whip is working and i do feel that the cracker, is making it a little bit easier to crack i don't know
If it's the whole weight of the whip or just the difference in having the cracker but i think, we have a slightly
higher pitched sound with the cracker on this whip either way it cracks
I don't know if i can pull this off
That was both there you have it a few techniques on how to crack a
Whip and a way to build your bullwhip
A little bit faster than filling paracord with bee bees the bee bees in the paracord whip has a little bit more weight to it
Which i enjoy and it costs a little bit less to build the ball chain
Whip is definitely faster to put together because you don't have to fill any paracord with bee bees
Which can, be pretty time-consuming and of course if you, want to add a cracker onto the end of your whip it can
Make it work a little bit better i wouldn't necessarily
Say that it's a 50 times improvement over where i was before but i think it's probably, about 20 percent easier to crack with
The cracker on it a big shout out to adam cwm, for the inspiration, we got from his 15 minute bulwark, tutorial he's a
Whip tracking professional and we've put a link in the description so you can go check him out and tell him
We sent you again if you're, gonna be making a
Bullwhip, make sure you, take safety precautions wearing, eyewear and long sleeves so that if something goes wrong
You, don't injure yourself other than that this is a really fun build, that doesn't take too long especially if you
Use the chain rather than the bee bees thanks for joining us for this project
Today, and we'll see you in the next one talk to you then?
This, video, like most of our videos is brought to you, by electrical tape, electrical tape it holds the world together
Quit grabbing, each other, my cracker is tied itself in a knot
around the fall
I Don't know if there was something i was supposed to do to avoid, that probably even with the cracker around it like that
yep
Hey, guys it's grant here i'm not in a position to be in these videos right, now but that's exactly, why
nate's here nate is the man he's got some incredible talent and i think he could pretty much build anything so let him know in
The comments, what you, want to see and he can probably make it happen